[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
mobile mass shooting suspect ezekiel
kelly appears in court for the first
time following a rampage across the city
of memphis which left four dead and
several others injured plus dozens of
media outlets are fighting back against
requests from doomsday duo mom lori valo
dabel's attorneys as they seek to ban
cameras from court and the murder of
denmark health mr adelson and his family
have substantial wealth and the
financial means to flee mr adelson even
discussed with ms mcbanawa his intention
to flee in the event he was prosecuted
the victim's former brother-in-law
charlie adelson is back in court and
makes a plea for pre-trial release and
later the disappearance and death of
kristin smart jurors hear key evidence
from forensic specialists as father and
son paul and ruben flores stand trial in
the 1996 murder case law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to
coast welcome everyone to law on prime
daily i'm your host mike sacks the man
investigators say is responsible for a
killing rampage across the city of
memphis stands before a judge for the
first time after he allegedly opened
fire in a string of deadly shootings
some of which was live streamed on
social media nineteen-year-old ezekiel
kelly is being held without bond
following a night of deadly shootings in
which four people were killed and three
others were shot the mass mobile
shooting began in the early morning
hours on wednesday when kelly allegedly
shot 24 year old dwayne amir tunstall
while the two were with friends at a
north memphis home hours later around 4
30 that afternoon officers responded to
a second shooting where another man was
pronounced dead at the scene police
responded to an autozone store where
rodolfo burger was shot and seriously
injured police say that shooting was
broadcast live on facebook burger
remains in serious condition kelly then
allegedly shot and killed allison parker
in a carjacking and just before nine
that night corteria wright was shot and
killed 30 minutes later kelly was taken
into custody following a high-speed
chase with police he appeared before a
judge friday morning wearing a dark blue
jumpsuit and a face mask he did not
enter a plea and no bond was set but
kelly was appointed an attorney who
indicated she will request a gag order
be put in place the judge also
acknowledged the death penalty is
possible in this case kelly is set to be
back in court on tuesday now joining us
today our co-host terry austin and
criminal defense attorney josh ritter
now josh after reports of the shootings
the police warned people to shelter in
place and suspended bus service do you
think those were appropriate precautions
to stay safe during that uncertain time
mike it's a sad set of affairs of the
times that we live in that i can't
imagine if any attempt by the government
to protect their community would be seen
as overreacting right when we see these
mass shootings occurring at schools and
outside of schools at markets uh you
would think that they would take any
attempt to protect your community and
you got to understand too that at the
time that they were taking these
measures they didn't know what was
really going on it could have been that
there was more than one shooter involved
it could have been a coordinated effort
they didn't know if this was random or
if it was targeted so you can understand
why they would make any attempt to kind
of protect people including uh you know
asking people to shelter at home and
avoid a public transport so i don't
think it was an overreaction at all
maybe it saved some lives yeah and it
certainly made people be a feel more a
little
more safe during a time of chaos around
the city now terry during a press
conference memphis mayor jim strickland
underscored the importance of the truth
and sentencing law in tennessee now what
does that new law say
well that law is something that
everyone's talking about right now it
says that anyone charged with violent
crimes like a murder or rape or an
aggravated assault they have to serve
100
of their sentences and there are
arguments in favor of that it's one
thing it'll keep the violent criminals
in jail for as long as possible and
maybe cut back on some of the crime but
there are also arguments against the law
and one of it is that it doesn't provide
for leniency when you have individuals
who've been incarcerated and they've
been doing good behavior and they
deserve another chance the argument is
that those individuals shouldn't be in
jail for the entire term but only for a
percentage of the time plus the fact you
have to remember it costs money to house
and to feed and to educate all of these
individuals and if every prisoner were
in jail for the entire time it would be
a strain on the system yes the perpetual
tough on crime versus smart on crime
something people can say is soft on
crime they say tough on crime is too
punitive it's the constant policy debate
we're having in the states and federally
as well now switching now to chicago
where the only defendant testifying in
the r kelly sex prime case takes the
stand for the third day in a row as
prosecutors question the r b star's
one-time confidant 55-year-old kelly a
convicted sex offender here in new york
in a federal court now stands trial in
illinois on federal sex crimes charges
back in 2008 the singer was acquitted of
charges for creating a video of himself
having sex with a 14 year old at the
time the alleged victim and her family
denied their involvement but 16 years
later the accuser and her mother
testified for the prosecution saying
they lied about their involvement after
kelly threatened them kelly's former
business manager and co-defendant daryl
mcdavid has testified now for three days
straight he's been asked about kelly's
questionable behavior in the early 2000s
and testified that kelly's legal team
told him the sex tape was fake on friday
mcdavid took the stand once again this
time for cross-examination prosecutors
say he played a key role in funneling
money to women who said they had been
sexually abused by the singer
now also in celebrity news puerto rican
superstar ricky martin is suing his
nephew after he accused the singer of
incest and sexual abuse martin accuses
dennis sanchez-martin of extortion weeks
after he withdrew his sexual assault
complaint against his uncle sanchez
claimed he had a romantic relationship
with martin for seven months and that
martin didn't want it to end sanchez
also claimed martin didn't follow him on
social media and then he allegedly
published martin's phone number online
months later he filed a sexual assault
lawsuit against the former broadway star
and pop singer and asked for a
restraining order in july the case
against martin was dismissed now the
singer is claiming the accusations
against him have cost him millions of
dollars in lost income the lawsuit says
the harassment from sanchez continued
despite martin's nephew admitting under
oath that he had never been sexually
assaulted by the artist now still ahead
on long time daily requests from defense
attorneys for lori valo dabel to block
cameras from court hearings and they're
met with pushback from dozens of media
outlets but first charlie adelson who is
charged in connection to the death of
his former brother-in-law dan markell
appears in court to argue for pre-trial
release
[Music]
welcome back several updates to share in
the doomsday cult duo case involving
lori valo and her husband chad dabel as
the couple faces murder charges over the
deaths of valo's kids and dabel's former
wife first a judge has denied a request
from valo's defense team seeking to send
her case back to a grand jury to clarify
language in her criminal indictment the
couple are charged with multiple counts
of first-degree murder and conspiracy to
commit murder in the killings of valo's
children jj and tyler ryan and chad's
first wife tammy dabell lori's legal
team is all seeking to ban cameras from
the case for any upcoming hearings and
the trial set for next year this came
after the defense said media abused the
privilege to videotape when it zoomed in
on valo's face during a hearing last
month they argue cameras could be used
to zoom in on notes violating
attorney-client confidentiality rules on
thursday more than 30 news organizations
asked the judge to reject that request a
hearing on that is set for next week so
terry is lori valo dabel's attorney
making a valid argument here to ban
cameras from the courtroom given what we
just saw and heard
absolutely not it's not a valid argument
just because the camera zoomed in come
on give me a break the public has a
right to view the proceeding in fact the
attorney representing the media
basically said that news organizations
they cover these criminal trials because
it's on behalf of the public and they
want to ensure the public confidence in
the criminal justice system that was the
argument and i couldn't agree more with
that argument that council also noted
that there are trained technical
staffers in the courtroom they know not
to zoom in on notes so that was just an
argument i think that was meritless it
hasn't happened it's not going to happen
and i definitely think that in order to
make sure that the public has access to
this that you have to have cameras in
there and this particular case mike is
really important it's a case that
everybody knows about worldwide not just
in the us and it involves two young
children and the public wants to make
sure
that justice has been served so
definitely the cameras need to be in
there we'll see ultimately what occurs
but i think argument for the media is
the argument that should win yeah and
it's not the media's first rodeo here as
evidenced by the fact that we have a
station we're talking about right now
all these all these issues we have
trials all day long this is something
people know and people watch and the
people there are going to be
professional about about filming what's
there now josh dabo's criminal trial is
not expected for months but hearings are
being held to resolve legal issues what
other types of issues can we expect to
be argued moving forward
it's all about evidence they're all
going to be deciding about what is going
to be in front of the jury and what
should not be in front of the degree
they're creating the landscape of the
trial right they want to make sure this
is more important for people to
understand it much of the trial is done
before the trial right what happens
during trial taking witnesses all of
that should be fairly uh expected by the
attorneys
rarely do you have those kind of perry
mason type moments where you know
there's some sort of shocking evidence
that comes out so all of this is arguing
about what's going to be in front of the
jury and what shouldn't so that they all
understand the landscape and again
that's going to begin the trial and all
starting next year but right now these
pre-trial motions moving forward now
meanwhile an arrest warrant is issued
for kayla montgomery the stepmother of
harmony montgomery a new hampshire girl
who investigators believe was murdered
kayla was set to appear in court on
thursday to discuss her charges related
to harmony but unrelated to the child's
disappearance and death officials allege
montgomery lied to the new hampshire
department of health and human services
to collect welfare on harmony's behalf
when the girl was not in kayla's care
now the case of missing harmony
montgomery has gripped new england and
the nation for the last year after the
little girl likely disappeared in
november or december of 2019 but police
didn't know she was missing until nearly
two years later investigators announced
last month they believe harmony was
murdered though her body has never been
found her case turned from being a
missing person's case to a homicide
investigation and harmony's father adam
has also been arrested on related
charges but no one has been charged in
direct connection so far to her
disappearance now coming up on law and
crime daily accused murderer charlie
adelson appears in court as he faces
charges in the 2014 death of his former
brother-in-law florida state law
professor dan markell plus the trial of
father and son paul and reuben flores
jurors your key testimony for the
prosecution in the disappearance and
death case of kristin smart
[Music]
welcome back a judge rules charlie
adelson will stay behind bars pending
his trial as he faces charges for
allegedly orchestrating and paying for
the plot to kill his former
brother-in-law florida state law
professor dan markell who was murdered
eight years ago a judge denied adelson
eligibility for bond at a hearing friday
morning in florida markel had an ugly
split from charlie's sister wendy
adelson before his death as the families
fought over custody of the couple's two
sons markel was ambushed in his driveway
as he arrived home on july 18 2014 and
investigators have long suspected the
adelson family was involved it was later
determined adelson's then-lover
catherine mcbanwa allegedly hired two
gunmen to attack markel one of them
previously pleaded guilty in a deal with
prosecutors sigfredo garcia was
convicted in 2019 while magbanwa was
retried and convicted earlier this year
after the first jury was deadlocked
edelson was indicted in april for his
alleged involvement on friday edelson's
attorneys argued he should be granted
bond until his trial prosecutors argued
against it
charlie adelson is a classic flight risk
he faces charges of first-degree murder
conspiracy to commit murder and
solicitation to murder
and the very real prospect of spending
the rest of his life in prison
after
all these factors the serious murder and
other felony offenses with which mr
adelson is charged the overwhelming
weight of the evidence against him the
lengthy prison sentence he faces and the
very real risk that he would flee the
risk that he would corruptly influence
trial testimony and the risk that he
would conspire with or be influenced by
members of his family strongly support
the denial of mr adelson's motion for
pre-trial release throughout this horror
the markels continue to fight for
complete justice for their son and to be
reunited with their grandsons
the interests of the public and of the
markel family as victims of this heinous
crime support the denial of mr adelson's
motion
all right terry they're talking about
something called an arthur hearing what
is that and why is it important in this
case well it's critical in this case in
the state of florida they have arthur
hearings to determine whether or not
someone who's committed a capital
offense like murder whether or not they
are eligible for bond and it requires
the defendant to actually show that they
are eligible for a bond and there is
that procedure that both sides have to
abide by and for the accused to be
granted bond the defense attorney
basically has to prove to the judge that
there's not enough evidence to support
charges and that the defendant does not
pose a danger to society and that he's
not a flight risk so
really the prosecution has to show it
has all the evidence and that the
defendant is the flight risk and the
defendant has to argue just the opposite
many judges generally rule on the side
of caution and they basically say look
this is a capital offense it's violent
stay in jail until your trial and
hopefully your trial will come within a
speedy time right josh and you're a
criminal defense lawyer and you know
that in general in theory bail is not
about punishment it's about ensuring
someone returns to trial now in this
case based on the facts of this of what
we have here and they also consider
future dangerousness etc should charlie
adelson be released on bond
no
uh despite being a defense lawyer i got
to say no
for the reasons that terry laid out
right you're talking about conspiracy to
commit murder you're talking about
murder for hire you're talking about
lying in wait these are all the kind of
horrible things that a judge would be
concerned with and you're absolutely
right judges are risk adverse when they
hear about this type of a murder they
realize that several people were
involved the planning that went into it
the uh the risk of flight the evidence
against him i don't think there's any
way a judge would uh you know leave
their neck out there and take a chance
on this type of a defendant yeah it's
really something where no judge wants to
as you said leave their neck out there
because if something happens well that
could be on the judge and people would
be blaming that judge as well and no one
wants that meanwhile down in florida
also the trial for parkland school
shooter is set to begin next week
following a week-long break to continue
the defense's case now on february 14
2018 a then 19 year old gunman opened
fire at marjory stoneman douglas high
school in parkland florida 17 people
were killed and 17 more were injured in
october of late last year the gunman
pleaded guilty to all charges we still
expect to hear from the shooter's
brother zachary who is one of the nearly
80 witnesses testifying for the defense
a broward county jury will decide now
whether
whether the shooter receives life in
prison or the death penalty now
testimony is set to resume on monday and
when we come back key witness testimony
in the 1996 death case of kristin smart
his father and son paul and ruben flores
face murder and accessory charges now 26
years later
[Music]
welcome back a georgia man who was
previously convicted of concealing the
death of teacher and beauty queen tara
grinstead will not be granted a new
trial beau dukes appealed his march 2019
conviction arguing the court should not
have admitted his confessions and
statements to investigators at his trial
the court responded saying they found no
error in the trial or sentencing and
denied a new trial or a change to his
sentence of 25 years dukes was charged
alongside ryan duke in the 2005 death of
grinstead more than a decade after she
went missing dukes claimed duke
confessed to him that he had killed
grimsed and dumped her body the two
allegedly burned her body together
earlier this year duke was acquitted of
murder and assault charges but found
guilty of concealing and death he was
sentenced to 10 years now both men still
face charges in a neighboring county
related to burning grinstead's body and
in california jurors hear key
prosecution testimony from a forensic
expert in the california case of paul
and ruben flores as they stand trial for
the 1996 disappearance and death of
kristin smart smart disappeared after a
party 26 years ago paul flores was
reportedly the last person seen with her
walking her home that may night smart
was declared legally dead years later
though her body has never been found
paulin's father reuben had long been
suspected of being involved in her
disappearance last year the father and
son were arrested paul was charged with
murder his father with accessory after
the fact accused of covering up smart's
death and burying her body in his
backyard and later moving the remains
all day wednesday consisted of testimony
from a forensic expert testifying about
the property searches done at rubin's
home she said she helped process
evidence collected during those searches
saying there was the possible presence
of blood in a cargo trailer on rubin's
property jurors also heard from an
expert in trace evidence who analyzed
fibers found in the dirt behind ruben's
home she said she identified fibers that
were black brown blue and red smart
reportedly was wearing red and black
when she went missing court is set to
reconvene monday morning if convicted
paul faces 25 years to life in prison
his father faces up to three years
behind bars now josh experts testify
that human blood and matching fibers as
we heard were located in rubin's
property is that enough for a conviction
for such a long
case that's a long time since the case
was was last investigated
is that enough by itself no but it's
it's put together with everything else
that the prosecution has put on i think
yes you have to remember for the
prosecution this is a case of a death by
a thousand cuts no pun intended there
but what they're doing is they're trying
to get the juror to ask the question of
what are the chances what are the
chances that in the same house where
possible blood and fibers were found
that that same person had dog signal to
his bed at his dorm room what are the
chances that that same person would be
the person that was last seen with
tristan spark what are the chances that
that same person would be the one who
was changing his story about injuries
that he had the following day what are
the chances that that same person would
have wiretapped where he's having
conversations with his mother about
possibly uh you know finding holes in a
podcast discussing the case so you put
all of that together and no one piece of
evidence on its own does not stand it's
not a smoking gun but you add all of
these together and i think you have a
case that you can ask a jury beyond a
reasonable doubt to return a conviction
yeah terry josh is pretty bullish on
this and chris smart did in fact
disappear in 1996 so how difficult do
you think it'll be for the prosecution
to prove this case beyond a reasonable
doubt listen like all cold cases and
like all cases without a body this is
going to be very difficult and obviously
in order to get a conviction that
prosecution is going to have to prove
the case beyond a reasonable doubt if
just one juror has doubt there's not
going to be a conviction
and the witnesses on the stand
especially those experts they're going
to be grilled they already have been
grilled on cross-examination about their
techniques about any inconsistencies
they may have had in prior testimony so
that's going to give those jurors some
doubt and other witnesses who aren't
experts they're going to be questioned
about their memory there was one witness
who had a conversation and she said that
his eyes look cold well they're going to
be tested on all of that and that's
going to leave some doubt in those
jurors minds and you have to remember
also that the sheer lack of evidence
that's going to present a huge problem
they have these little trace samples of
blood and trace samples of fibers but is
that enough and so i think it's going to
be very difficult for that prosecution
that's right my amazing co-host terry
austin and josh vader criminal defense
lawyer thank you guys very much for
joining us here today and thank you all
watching for joining us here on lawn
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you